alors Jean Sarkozi on le disait la
controverse n'a pas cessé est-ce que
vous serez toujours malgré cela candidat
demain au conseil d'administration de
l'Pad et plus tard candidat à sa
présidence bonsoir David Pujadas si je
suis venu chez vous pour m'exprimer
c'est bien pour rendre compte de ce qui
va se passer demain je serai candidat au
poste d'administrateur de l'Pad devant
l'assemblée départementale mais si je
suis élu je ne brierai pas la présidence
de cet établissement public et je veux
m'en expliquer vous savez depuis
plusieurs jours il y ap beaucoup de
choses qui ont été dites beaucoup
d'excès beaucoup de caricature beaucoup
d'outrance puis il y a du vrai aussi moi
j'ai beaucoup écouté j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi et je ne veux pas d'une
victoire qui porte le poids d'un tel
soupçon euh c'est une décision que je
prends en mon âme et conscience qui
n'est pas évidente qui est difficile
mais en tout cas je n'accepte pas que ce
soupçon de de favoritisme de passe-
droit ou de traitement de faveur puisse
peser c'est votre décision
personnelle c'est ma décision bien
entendu c'est une décision quiprz ce je
vous dire c'est est-ce que c'est votre
père le président qui vous a conseillé
de le faire qui vous a demandé de le
faire ou est-ce que c'est vous qui
l'avez souhaité si la question vous me
poser c'est est-ce que vous en avez
parlé au président non est-ce que j'en
ai parlé avec mon père oui il est comme
tous les pères et je suis comme tous les
fils et naturellement dans des moments
qui sont difficiles nous parlons
ensemble je lui ai fait part de ma
décision c'est une décision que j'ai
pris seu et que j'assume seul en
conséquence c'est dans cet esprit que
j'ai souhaité être candidat à la défense
pourquoi j'ai souhaité être candidat et
pourquoi je serai candidat au Conseil
d'Administration parce que j'ai des
convictions parce que j'ai des idées que
je veux défendre pour l'avenir de ce
quartier d'affaires qui a 50 ans et dont
il faudra préparer les 50 prochaines
années pour le rénover pour le préparer
au défi faut asseoir son leadership il
faut conforter son attractivité ça je le
ferai comme administrateur je le ferai
humblement je le ferai en en travaillant
comme je le fais depuis 2 ans mais je ne
veux pas du soupçon mais je ne veux pas
d'une victoire entachée de soupçon on va
reparler mais jusqu'à ces dernières
heures les ministres les parlementaires
de la majorité tout le monde défendait
votre choix de vous porter candidat à
cette présidence ça signifie que votre
décision vient d'être prise parce
qu'apparemment elle prend tout le monde
par
surprise j'ai beaucoup réfléchi et je
vous l'ai dit est-ce que j'ai fait une
erreur est-ce que j'ai fait une faute on
ne fait jamais une erreur quand on est
candidat à une élection on ne fait
jamais une faute quand on s'engage on ne
fait jamais une erreur quand on a envie
de se battre qu'est-ce que c'est la
défense la défense c'est un enjeu qui
concerne le département dont je suis
l'élu et que j'ai envie de servir vous
savez il y a eu une campagne de
désinformation je l'ai déjà dit
orchestré de manière professionnelle un
soupçon est né à cause de cette campagne
s'est installé on a parlé de népotisme
on a parlé de nomination chacun a bien
compris qu'il en était pas le cas on a
parlé aussi d'une rémunération alors que
ce n'était pas un problème d'argent pu
c'est une responsabilité et je veux dire
que ma candidature elle était pleinement
légitime je ne reviens en aucun cas sur
ce que j'ai dit pourquoi parce que je
suis conseiller général parce que c'est
une responsabilité que les 44 autres
conseillers généraux des hautes scènes
pouvaient briguer au même titre que moi
ce n'est donc pas un problème de
légitimité j'ai été élu c'est mes
électeurs ce sont mes électeurs qui ont
décidé de m'offrir la
possibilité de m'exprimer et je n'ai pas
été élu pour aller une fois ou deux
voter en séance du conseil général mais
bien pour y assumer des responsabilités
mais vous dites il y avait aussi une
part de vrai dans ces critiques quelle
est cette part de vrai selon vous est-ce
que vous reconnaissez que d'une certaine
manière peut-être on vous avait préparé
le terrain ouvert la voix ou pas c'est
pas ce que je suis en train de dire je
dis que pendant 15 jours on a assisté à
une véritable campagne de manipulation
et de désinformation on a parlé
d'intrigue on a parlé de manœuvre on a
parlé de nomination on a parlé de choses
qui étaient est fausse mais pour autant
moi je souhaite défendre mes convictions
le faire au conseil d'administration de
l'Pad je ne cours pas après les titres
je ne cours pas après les honneurs c'est
pas ça le sens de mon engagement
politique et je ne veux pas que ce
soupçon puisse peser sur l'engagement
qui est le mien c'est pour ça que je ne
souhaite pas être candidat à présid rien
de vrai dans les critiques que vous avez
entendu vous avez mentionné ça mais vous
savez qu'est-ce que je suis en train
d'essayer de vous dire c'est pas évident
pour moi de venir devant vous comme
devant des millions de Français pour
expliquer la décision que je dois le
prendre mais je le fais parce que
j'assume mes responsabilités et face à
tout ce qui a été dit moi j'ai j'ai
écouté j'ai voulu me faire une opinion
j'ai voulu prendre du recul et j'ai
voulu surtout être conscient que on ne
fait pas de la politique tout seul on
fait de la politique parce qu'on aime
les gens et quand on aime les gens on
veut les comprendre et quand on veut les
comprendre on se met à leur place on
écoute ce qu'ils disent c'est pour ça
que j'ai pris cette décision et c'est
pour ça que je suis devant vous ce soir
pour vous dire est-ceil y a de
l'amertume en vous ce soir puisque vous
prenez une décision tout en pensant que
finalement elle n'est pas vraiment
justifiée puisque ces critiques ne
l'étaient pas non plus est-ce qu'il y a
de l'amertume quel est votre état d'espr
n'est pas ce que j'ai dit il y a aucune
amertume chez moi les critiques font
partie du combat politique je ne m'en
plains pas même si je peux estimer que
ma candidature que toute candidature à
une élection serait légitime mais en
même temps mon devoir c'est de prendre
conscience d'une situation qui peut me
dépasser d'en prendre acte et je ne suis
pas sourd je ne suis pas aveugle et je
décide en conséquence je n'ai aucune
amertume mais naturellement j'ai
beaucoup appris j'ai beaucoup appris de
ce qui n'est pas un échec ce qui est une
épreuve qu'il faut traverser qu'il faut
assumer dont il faut tirer des leçons
c'est ce que je fais devant vous vous
ser pas candidat le 4 décembre prochain
à la présidence est-ce que vous
envisagez de l'être dans quelques années
ou un peu plus tard tout simplement
est-ce que c'est simplement j'allais
dire partie remise ou est-ce que vous y
renoncez purement et simplement la
question la question ne se pose pas est
pas d'actualité ce qui est certain c'est
que je mènerai des combats dans les
années qui viennent devant les électeurs
votre ambition n'est pas entamé je mais
pourquoi le serait-elle j'ai une
vocation politique j'ai une passion pour
l'engagement politique j'ai une passion
pour mon département rien ne pourrait
entamer cette passion je fais le choix
de la raison au fond ce qu'on a dit
c'est ce qu'on peut-être à 23 ans
capable de maturité j'ai dit laissons
parler les actes je fais un choix de
raison je fais un choix de raison qui
n'altère en rien la passion que j'ai
pour cet engagement politique cette
passion elle est inaltérée parce que
David Pujadas elle est inaltérable et je
continuerai et je dis à ceux qui m'ont
soutenu je dis aussi à mes amis
que les combats politiques que je
mènerai dans les années qui viennent je
les mènerai à leur côté devant les
électeurs et c'est les électeurs qui
décideront comme ils l'ont décidé en
2008 en faisant de moi un conseiller
général alors on parle de cette ambition
ce sera ma dernière question est-ce que
vous envisagez comme c'est écrit souvent
d'être candidat à la présidence par
exemple du conseil général en 2011 là
encore la question n'est pas d'actualité
demain j'ai un grand rendez-vous devant
l'assemblée départementale devant
l'ensemble des conseillers généraux je
vais leur proposer ma candidature pour
administrateur à l'panne je vais leur
dire ce que je veux faire comme
administrateur pour le quartier
d'affaires après il sera le temps de
proposer un projet il sera le temps de
l'incarner ce qui est certain c'est que
je suis président de la majorité
départementale parce que j'ai été élu
par mes pères parce que j'ai mérité la
confiance de mes pères et si la question
que vous me posez c'est est-ce que vous
allez continuer à travailler pour
mériter cette confiance alors comptez
sur moi je serai au rendez-vous merci
Jean Sarkozy d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions y